hello there region technician it's greg
alba i just got back from watching
nineteen seventeen on imax wow i can
tell why it is getting all the buzz and
all the award it's fantastic come to
find out this black widow special look
drop while i was on the way home tried
getting ahold of John won't pick up his
phone doesn't he know that he should
have his phone on him by all times in
case something comes out on the internet
that must be covered right away whatever
we're gonna have to do this without him
I like these marvels special looks to
capitalize on all that awesome ScarJo
action that's been going around with the
Oscars lately let's check this out now
shall we
[Music]
[Music]
nice yes steal fits ha ha that's what I
say oh wow
housemaster her
it's probably a girl oh so cool so cool
I feel like it's palate just looks so
different than all the other MCU movies
man have we not gotten the official this
is still not even the official trailer
yet that teaser trailer there's like
these cuts that they made on YouTube
where they have like extended
soundtracks of the trailer song from the
first black widow trailer listen to that
at the gym sometimes yeah that's a
bitchin song right there in terms of
what this special look gave us it gave
us a clearer look at some of these
family vibes that you're getting here
between red Guardian Alaina Bulova it
seems like so much of the driving force
the heart the dynamic beyond the family
vibes with Rachel vices character and
David harbors character it seems like
the main central focus will be with
Florence pew and Scarlett Johansson
Florence POA we just did a live stream a
few hours ago she's gonna be like a
superstar one day with her work and
fighting with my family people been
saying they feel she got gypped on her
hospitalization for mid samar and
knowledge she's gonna get an Oscar
nomination through this she looks like
she could potentially be a scene stealer
you know as excited as I am to learn
some more specifics and details
reoccurring theme black widow who's
tired of running away from her past it's
the in Samba surrounding her that I'm
really most excited for in this film and
so much of these action set-pieces
really do remind me of other spy action
flicks like bond like mission impossible
especially mission impossible and then
there are action scene moments that
remind me of what the Russo brothers did
with Captain America's Civil War or
Winter Soldier except the camera motion
looks a little bit more steady here
and something that I'm really excited
for - with this film and it's T's here
is a lot of the hand-to-hand combat
they're talking about all the widows
here so I feel like we're gonna get a
whole bunch of badass females getting a
whole lotta ass together and against one
another as well and I think when you're
giving Black Widow her own solo outing
you need to have her up against
antagonists or villains that are more in
the Hanahan combat style or gunplay and
of course like these better looks at
taskmaster I don't
think we know exactly who's playing
taskmaster in this film the impression
I'm getting is that it could be one of
the widow's probably rachel weisz but
either way that last few moments that
you got with the taskmaster mirroring or
mimicking you know part of his abilities
or her abilities that looked pretty
freakin neat and I think with these
trailers if they've read Guardian David
Harbor has really shined a lot orange
pew she got to shine a lot more on this
trailer as well get a better look at
taskmaster hood on hood off I want to
see a little bit more Rachel Weisz
something that makes her performance
feel a lot more unique a lot more
different but something tells me a lot
of that performance will shine through
in her chemistry with David Harbor that
line at the waterways gosh so accurate
hit a sauna and it won't make a
difference but I'll still use it as an
excuse and I'm loving the music that's
been in both of these trailers I hope
it's the kind of music that's actually
in the film itself and the
cinematography overall it just looks
really so this looks feels different I'm
excited for this home I find it funny
they drop this special look the same day
as Morbius which Morbius went out of his
way to clearly show you that it's MCU
connected it's weird how the Black Widow
trailer the teaser one came in at
midnight this one a 9:30 p.m. I'm not
sure who its marketing to at this
specific hour either way it's gonna go
trending probably number one on the
Internet guys tell me the comp boxes
what did you like more
Morbius trailer or this Black Widow
special look bunch of hot babes kicking
ass the whole time yeah a film for both
genders alright guys well thank you for
watching do the thing that's flashing up
here on screen yep yep you know what to
do yeah yeah that's right very good and
I'd like to end this video with a patron
today shout out to a woman named el b CL
b recently messaged her on patreon she
told me that her main resolution this
year is to save up money and remodel her
kitchen why because she seduces guys
into her room and then murders them and
last time that happened it went down a
little too chaotic destroyed the entire
interior of her living room and kitchen
so to keep up appearances and for
seduction purposes she has to remodel
the whole kitchen to make sure it
looks good before she does her next kill
don't worry lb I won't show your face on
screen that way your identity is kept
secret so you can still perform the
necessary tasks of the master of skill
that you you do you widow it ties in
somehow you're a woman